this winter
tens of millions of British citizens
including children will be tipped or
dumped into energy poverty severe enough
to risk permanent damage to their health
cold damp houses provide the perfect
breeding ground for mold that not only
causes respiratory distress
but renders houses essentially unlivable
once established
one left-leaning newspaper ran the story
outlining the danger but without a word
about why this crisis has emerged
because the woke moralizers of the
environmental movement helped create it
compassion callow self-aggrandizing
incompetent politicians there are
celebrity lackeys Machiavellian
journalists
have insisted ever more loudly over the
last five decades that no cost was and
is too great for others to bear in the
pursuit of blind service to the planet
it is irresistibly tempting at the
moment for those on that bandwagon to
single out and demonize Vladimir Putin
for Europe's energy woes but his current
machinations were utterly enabled by the
green ideologues anyone with eyes could
see a decade ago that the idiot insists
that Europe make itself reliant on
Russia for its energy security made the
current situation
inevitable
remember when President Donald Trump
populist Menace Numero Uno was marked
and derided by the intellectual and
political Elite in Europe and North
America for trumpeting precisely that
warning well now the chickens have truly
come home to roost
but very little has yet been learned in
consequence
virtue signaling utopians committed to
globalization claim we are destroying
the planet with cheap energy
but are they truly and deeply committed
to the environmental sustainability so
loudly and insistently demanded or they
merely hell bent in the prototypically
Marxist manner
in taking revenge on capitalism
it appears to be the latter
why otherwise would the mavens of the
environmental movement oppose nuclear
power
despite its optimal carbon footprint
why would they demonize the
exceptionally clean natural gas whose
fracking enabled production has allowed
the U.S to dramatically cut the very
carbon output that is so hypothetically
undesirable
utility bills have soared in the UK the
home of the Industrial Revolution that
lifted the world out of poverty
now up to half of small businesses in
Britain face the risk of bankruptcy and
closure
the government has had to announce a
ruinously expensive energy price
guarantee to mitigate the worst effects
of This Disaster
the rush to Renewables
the mentality among the eco-extremists
is as follows
if we have to Doom the poor to destroy
the system that made the rich so be it
you just can't make an omelet without
breaking a few eggs
here are some facts to remember well we
so madly and ineffectively rush to
Renewables
the International Energy agency recently
indicated that two decades of intense
support for such undertakings has hiked
the proportion of energy provided by
such means from 13 to 14 percent
to an utterly underwhelming
15.7 percent
if all governments deliver on their
current climate policies the world will
derive no more than 28 percent of its
energy that way by 2050. and a hundred
percent by
2207
not 20 30 or 2035 but 200 years later
does anyone on the liberal left accept
such projections or are they a mere
fabrication of the conspiratorial
right-wing conservative imagination
how about the Biden Administration
Biden's experts no doubt motivated to be
as optimistic as possible project that a
mere 27 percent of the energy produced
by 2050 will be carbon dioxide free and
that full CO2 eradication cannot
possibly occur
until 2242
42
an even more dismal guesstimation if you
regard such realities as dismal then
that put forth by the International
Energy agency
but
the tyrannical and emergency Justified
panicked crunch is not just happening in
the UK
in Spain officials now dictate that
commercial properties must not be heated
above 17 degrees Celsius or cool below
27 degrees Celsius upon pain of law
in Switzerland similar punishments are
being considered as part of a proposed
four-step plan for dealing with a gas
shortage which quote cannot be ruled out
this winter given the geopolitical
situation
the citizens of Germany likewise are now
in phase two of a three-stage emergency
plan following a reduction in gas flows
from Russia its main supplier
the plan involves bringing coal-fired
plants onto the market according to
German Minister Robert habeck
despite them being quote simply poisoned
for the climate
and the potential of gas rationing for
industrial companies
so that supplies to homes and schools
Etc are not disrupted
the extended plan involves curtailing
the Christmas lighting that constitutes
part of the celebration in the midst of
the winter darkness in many locations
where they generally shine
nothing either beautiful or pleasing is
acceptable in the least to the grinches
and the Grinch was in fact green when
confronted by the crisis they created
remember
when the aristocracy catches cold The
Peasants die of pneumonia
if such Extreme Measures have become
necessary in the richest countries
what in God's name is going to happen in
the poorer ones
when the shortages strike the poor will
inevitably and necessarily turn to less
green resources many even in Germany are
already stockpiling firewood and coal
for the winter leading to acute
shortages
how is incentivizing people to cut down
and burn trees and use coal in their
fireplaces going to help reduce the
dreaded atmospheric carbon load
the actual poor versus the hypothetical
poor
perhaps we'll be able to comfort
ourselves here in the west with the
thought that the food we take for
granted will still be available at our
tables
but wait
the crops that nourish our populations
cannot be grown without fertilizer
loathed by Green folk and more
specifically without ammonia
and what pray tell is ammonia derived
from
could it be
Natural Gas
and how many people are dependent for
their daily bread on the industrial
generation and consequent white
availability of ammonia
only three or four billion
what happens to the continuous
production plants responsible for making
ammonia if the natural gas supplies are
halted even momentarily
they destroyed themselves as they were
not designed for such an unlikely event
and they cannot be restarted
the World Bank itself has recently
indicated that 222 million people
are already experiencing the threat of
starvation
described oh so nicely as food
insecurity
the Communists managed to kill a hundred
million in the last century with their
utopian delusions
we've barely begun to implement the Save
the Planet Nightmare and we've already
placed twice that number at risk
we are told an emergency confronts us
the climate crisis
the solution
the masses will have to tighten their
belts
to forestall an even worse future
catastrophe
the elite academics think tanks and
corporate consultants and the
politicians who subsidize their
intellectual pretensions
will not be particularly affected by
such tightening privileged as they are
but the actual poor
to such an elite they must be sacrificed
now to save tomorrow's hypothetical poor
and 222 million people is no doubt an
underestimate
as the food insecurity gets more severe
more countries will place restrictions
on food exports
that will harm the international supply
lines we all depend on
then when the consequences of that
manifest themselves increasingly
desperate politicians will begin to
nationalize and centralize food
distribution as the French and Germans
have already done on the energy front
and cut their Farmers off at the knees
who will in turn stop growing food not
out of spite
but because of dire economic
impossibility
then we will have engendered the kind of
feedback loop that can really spiral out
of control
it will be poor people who die first at
least
but as we all have all been taught by
the malevolent eco moralizers
the planet has too many people on it
anyway
think about this well you shiver all too
soon in your cold damp and increasingly
expensive and now substandard lodgings
you and your family may well have been
deemed an Expendable excess
food for thought
this is simply not acceptable
if you dare to claim the moral High
Ground well serving the cause of
starvation then by my Reckoning
you've placed yourself firmly in the
enemy camp and you richly deserve
whatever is coming your way
in the psychological and educational
Arenas too we demoralize young people
feeding them a constant diet of
concretized Apocalypse focusing
particularly on tempering or even
obliviating the laudable ambition of
boys hectoring them into believing that
their virtue is nothing
but the force that oppresses the
innocent and despoils the virginal
planet
and if that doesn't work and it does
then there's always the castration
awaiting the gender dysphoric
and you oppose such initiatives at
substantial personal risk
but we can reassure ourselves with the
fact that a beneficient government is
going to set up warm spots in public
libraries and museums this winter so
that freezing starving old people can
huddle together to keep warm
well their grandchildren cough up their
lungs in their frigid damp and moldy
Flats
in such circumstances in the face of
such mandatory privations and
manipulations it's obvious that the last
thing are tyrannical idiot panicked
virtue signaling government should be
doing
is directing their demented attention
toward regulating what people serve at
their tables but because meat has also
been deemed yet something else that is
destroying the planet the woke
narcissists of compassion are already
insisting that people eat less of it
plants and bugs for you and your
children peasants
and the sooner you get accustomed to it
or else
the better
let's turn our attention to the claim
that animal husbandry and the meat it
produces cheaply enough for everyone to
afford is unsustainable
for a moment because we haven't yet
dispensed with enough moralizing and
authoritarian stupidity
remember what happened the last time the
government agencies applied their tender
Mercy to determining what the people
they serve should consume
we were offered the much vaunted food
pyramid telling us to eat
6 to 11 servings of grains and
carbohydrates a day
with protein and fat at the Pinnacle
something to be indulged in with
comparative Rarity if indeed necessary
at all
that all turned out to be wrong and not
just a little wrong but so wrong that it
might as well have been not just wrong
but a veritable anti-truth something as
wrong as it could possibly get
the food pyramid was brought into being
not least by the U.S department of
Agriculture that is by marketers not
scientists or nutritionists with no
shortage whatsoever of Lobby efforts by
those whose products ended up being
promoted
the dietary recommendation to prioritize
carbohydrates
produced a veritable epidemic of obesity
a diabetes resulting in what has been
deemed by reliable researchers as one of
the worst Public Health disasters of all
time doing almost the entire Western
population to a lifetime of catastrophic
chronic health problems
42 percent of Americans are obese
another almost equally large percentage
are overweight at least a third are in
the early or later stages of diabetes
which is an exceptionally serious
disease
1.7 trillion dollars is spent annually
on chronic illness in the U.S
and the rise in such illness and cost
is directly associated with the
beginning of the god forsaken top-down
dietary guidelines that set us all on a
carbohydrate heavy dietary pathway
there have been in addition dozens of
studies debunking the claim that red
meat causes disease
the purer study p-u-r-e published in the
journal landsat in 2017 analyzing 140
000 individuals from 18 countries
revealed that quote higher carbohydrate
intake
not meat and fat note was associated
with an increased risk of total
mortality and that quote higher
saturated fat intake
was associated with lower risk of stroke
lower
that is exactly the opposite of what we
have been told by The Beneficial
centralizing agents who tasked
themselves with determining what we as
Sovereign and responsible individuals
should put in our mouths
so the health benefits of a pure
vegetarian and vegan diet are dubious at
best
but what of the argument that animal
husbandry is killing the planet
well the American Environmental
Protection Agency estimates that all
farming produces only 11 percent of
greenhouse gases in the U.S
Transportation produces 27 percent
livestock accounts
for three percent
and plant-based agriculture
five percent
according to the National Academy of
Sciences if we eradicated all
animal-based agriculture we'd reduce
greenhouse gases by a mere 2.6 percent
and it is no simple matter by the way
and perhaps impossible to manage a diet
that is sustainable in the medium to
long term by merely dining on plants
chew on that
Exodus
the pathway forward
what might we do instead if we chose to
be genuinely wise instead of inflicting
want and privation upon the world's poor
while failing utterly and disastrously
to save the planet
we could begin by assuming here in the
west that all those frightened into
paralysis and enticed into tyranny by
their apprehension of the pending
apocalypse have bitten off more than
they can properly chew
have taken on a dragon much more fire
breathing and dire than they are heroic
have failed entirely to contend with the
moral hazard
that comes in assuming that the faddish
emergency of their overheated
imaginations entitles them to the use of
power and compulsion
if your apprehension of the looming
catastrophe whatever its form has made
you into a terrified authoritarian
willing to frighten and compel to get
your way
you are simply not the right leader for
the times
as the unconscious manifestations of
your own nervous system telling you that
you are just too small for the job at
hand are clearly indicating
even to you
we could begin by dropping our appalling
attitude of moral superiority toward the
developing world
we could admit instead that the rest of
the planet's inhabitants have the right
and the responsibility to move toward
the abundant material life that we have
enjoyed despite ourself
for the last century and which has been
so entirely dependent on Industrial
activity and fossil fuel usage
we could work diligently and with
purpose to drive energy and food prices
down to the lowest level possible
so that we can ease the burden on the
poor and open up the horizons of
possibility so that they become
concerned as they inevitably and
properly will with long-term
sustainability instead of acting
desperately and destructively in pursuit
of their next meal
we could concentrate on an intelligent
plan of stewardship instead of
anti-human environmentalism
along the lines of the plans outlined by
multifaceted and diligent experts such
as Dr Bjorn lomberg who pointed out
years ago that we have a multitude of
crises facing us and not just one the
hypothetically apocalyptic danger of
carbon
and that we could spend the money we are
wasting killing poor people
in a much more intelligent judicious
manner
devoting some resources for example to
ensuring a stable food supply to poor
children in the developing world
treating malaria something we can do and
cheaply and delivering fresh water where
it is truly needed
we could as well work out the details of
a truly sustainable agriculture with the
most expert farmers
to improve the quality of our soil
and the air
and provide everyone with enough high
quality food
which will most definitely involve
animal-based agriculture we could bring
a halt to the presumption that the state
should extend Itself by Dent of its
hypothetical moral superiority to the
governance of how we heat our houses and
feed and provision our own families
we could finally
delegate authority to the most local
possible of levels
following the principle of subsidiarity
and produce a hierarchy of
responsibility that extends necessary
purpose to everyone individually at the
family and community and state level and
that serves as a necessary bulwark
against the Blind and luciferian
prideful intellect-based top-down
tyrannies of emergency and compulsion
that will otherwise necessarily reign
we could work out our concerns with
sustainability through consensus
and in the spirit of voluntary
Association and free play instead of
relying on top-down edicts justified in
principle by our misplaced existential
Terror and carrying with them the moral
hazard of the accrual of unjustified and
dangerous centralized Authority
we could distribute to everyone their
requisite responsibility as Sovereign
actors and could bring them on board
with the power of a common vision
one of life more abundant enough high
quality food for everyone enough energy
so that slavery becomes a thing of the
past
enough purpose so that nihilism and
decadence no longer beckon
enough reciprocity so that we live in
true peace
the generous provision of education and
opportunity to everyone in the world
the conviction to say it again that
policy based on compulsion is misguided
and counterproductive
we could thereby have our cake and eat
it too and so could everyone else
and we could work toward that in a
mutual Spirit of productive generosity
and fair play in competition and
cooperation
or we could let the world go to hell in
a handbasket
blame that disintegration on the very
enemies we specified as causal in the
first place those damned capitalists and
failed to clean up our own Souls as we
persecute the imaginary wrongdoers
responsible for the destruction of our
planet
identifying the real Danger
has the psychologist Carl Jung said in
the aftermath of the Nazi atrocities and
the use of nuclear weapons quote it is
becoming more and more obvious that it
is not starvation not microbes not
cancer
but man himself who is Mankind's
greatest Danger
for the simple reason that there is no
adequate protection against psychic
epidemics
which are infinitely more devastating
than the worst of natural catastrophes
that great man knew the technological
man had a stark choice in front of him
to become as ethical as he had become
powerful
and that a real hell awaited if we
refused the challenge
the rate of change is accelerating our
ability to do almost everything is
doubling faster and faster
as our ability to communicate and to
compute accelerates the consequence of
our inner disunity and insufficiency
become ever more serious
as we become individually more powerful
in other words we must take on more
responsibility
or else
if we fail to rectify our personal
pathologies of Pride envy and the
willingness to lie
we will find ourselves mired in conflict
with the world both natural and social
and in precise proportion to our refusal
to check the Devil Within
so we have a stark choice in front of us
we can reorient ourselves to the cause
of Truth
or we can act out the conflict imposing
ourselves serving instrumental delusions
on the world bringing about in that
manner an external apocalypse
that will result in precisely the same
judgment
and so in conclusion
it's time for all of us but especially
the self-righteous moralizers to get our
individual acts together
to take on some real moral
responsibility
instead of falsely broadcasting unearned
virtue far and wide and so cheaply and
carelessly